do you see with jacket it's crazy i
thought he meant you selling
one nft for like a hundred grand i
didn't or however much you sold that
like what's the difference between a
jpeg and an nft thing
i didn't see that you have one for 76
million dollars
just put it up this morning do you think
that's gonna work look at this
i love it
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road
uh just kind of an update on my bitcloud
thing that i wanted to talk about but we
can do it
we can do it later if we want it doesn't
have to be at the beginning
uh what i would rather you you t you
lead it unless you want to talk about
jack butcher
like we have a ton of like this is all
related
crazy there's like the world is so weird
right now and
amongst our friends i think that there's
probably a tier or two above
but we are in such an odd tier where we
have very close friends
or you and me a little bit but less so
have
made a fair amount of money on all of
this new stuff happen
yeah it's kind of crazy so i'll say if
you're tired of us talking about
bitcoin and nfts and all the crypto
stuff
um this is probably not it'll probably
skip ahead to the part where we're gonna
talk about
you know dictionary.com later so so i
would say we're gonna go
we're gonna show you some range today
we're gonna talk about a website that's
like
25 years old and then we're going to
talk about uh you know
a website that's like 25 minutes old
which is uh big cloud so
let's talk about jack first okay so we
have a friend jack butcher
who is uh he's behind this account
that's kind of
very popular on twitter called visualize
value he himself was kind of like a
designer background so very like kind of
artistic guy and um by the way
every time i say artistic i think i'm
about to say autistic and so i have to
like you know catch myself each time
make sure
i didn't call them autistic so it could
be that who knows
well actually the thing about jack is
he's very smooth very very low-key
nicest guy in the world and uh i met i
met
jack a year ago a year ago i contacted
him and asked him to do this design
stuff and then he was
just up and coming right and sarah and i
my wife
became friends with jack and his wife
and
we they spent thanksgiving with us down
here in austin where uh they just had a
baby and we've been
friends with them talking all that stuff
and he
did his story is that he used to live in
new york city him and his wife he's
british he he came here 10 years ago
they shared a one bedroom or sorry a
studio apartment that was 400
square feet and he was they were nothing
i mean they were they they were they
tried to start an agency business they
didn't go so well and they were on their
last dollar and this is only like 18
months ago
right okay so so he he kind of pivots to
basically saying okay within the agency
it's work that i do the part that i like
and i'm good at and other people don't
seem to like what they really want
are these like pitch decks i'm making
i'm really good at making these slides
where it's just a rectangle and i
communicate some information on it
and so that's where the visualized value
brand came from was he's just putting
out like
a little you know like an image a
rectangle that would take a concept
and like bring it to life visually and
so he started off getting popular by
just taking a bunch of naval's
uh popular tweets you know sayings his
little kind of one-liners
and he would create a graphic out of it
and he has this one graphic style
if you're on twitter you've seen it it's
just black and white uh it's always a
black background with white text on top
and a little kind of like
very simplistic minimalistic um
like graph or chart or drawing on top of
it okay so
that's visualized value so he does like
the normal creator thing he gets a
little bit of an audience his twitter
goes to a hundred thousand people
he creates a course he creates kind of
like a paid community for people who
want to learn this thing
and he's doing well for himself right
and that's where we met very well
and he he he's it does he does north of
a million dollars a year in revenue
and the only uh expenses
are like small software stuff and then
him and his wife exactly
and um so he's doing he's doing very
well for himself right
but it's all relative she's doing much
better now so what happened
um this craze around nfts came out and
if you don't know what nft is just think
of it like digital art
that people buy and uh crypto people
people really like it because it's
virtual art in the same way that crypto
is
sort of like a virtual money or a
digital money so anyways
jack starts doing nfts so jack basically
takes his same art that he's posting on
twitter for free
and he's like no now you can own this
piece of art so now you can own this
post that i'm putting up
and so he just dabbles you know just
does an experiment i don't know what the
first one sold for i think it was like
one ether right uh one when he used two
two or three thousand dollars
yeah just close to two grand and uh it
was like 1.5 ether or something like
that so it's like two or three thousand
bucks
still pretty sweet right like this is
just a you know dot png file that he
otherwise uploads to twitter for free
and now somebody wanted to own the png
file because they're fans of his and
this
meant something to them and they had a
bunch of crypto gains that they could
reinvest their chucky cheese money right
and so um
okay so now he's like stepping it up so
we'll fast forward
he does some more nfts he releases
another nft this one gets
bid up and gets bought for 33 eth
which is i think something like um what
does 33e 338
times like 70 grand it's like 70 grand
so he sells one of his
images for 70 grand okay and i called
him
right when i saw that i go jack is this
real did someone he goes
yeah it's crazy mate that's all i said
right right exactly because he's not
like
he's not like a schemer in any way but i
think he is smart and he is interesting
he likes to dabble but like he wasn't
he's not trying to pull a quick one he's
like putting his art out there and
people are buying it and so i actually
message the buyer
and i go why the heck do you buy this
thing it's some random you know random
username he just goes oh you know i love
jack
and i think this is going to appreciate
value and i you know
i just really love this like i just love
the i love the art
and i was like wow okay fantastic so
that's the guy bought it for 70 grand
so then he did something even crazier
which
i'm talking about the packs do you know
the packs
yeah so to explain that one so the
the part of the story is the the crate
there's two crazy parts of the story the
most recent thing that happened which
we'll talk
but the first crazy thing is he was like
you know
what if i did like people love jack he's
got a cult following probably more than
sean people love shawn they used to love
me then they moved to sean now they
love johnny love jack and what he did
was he created a website where
you were buying a pack he had 12 packs
all it said was pack one pack two pack
three it looked like a imagine like a
baseball card but with a jack butcher
cover on it it was just black and it
said visualize value pack one
right and you would buy these packs
having no idea what the nft art was in
it
right he had 12 of them and people were
bidding on them and each one
sold for around 10 to 15 000 which is
i thought amazing until we get to the
final part of the story or
at least the most recent part of the
story exactly so he so he gets to
today i log on to twitter as i do first
thing in the morning
uh what's going on in the world tonight
holy [__] jack butcher has listed a new
piece of art for 76 million dollars
something like that what is this what's
the exact number 72 76 million
he basically and it's called fame and
what he did was
the most the highest um priced nft
thus far in the history of mankind was
people
the the artist people uh who's like jack
but even more popular
so people had done a a few drops those
drops were like kind of in the one to
five million range-ish
and then the most popular
nft of all time was sold for 69 million
dollars recently
and like there's some rumors that like
that was sort of a manufactured sale
like somebody came in and did it just to
like
they're gonna like i don't know these
are rumors but rumors were that they
kind of made a publicity stunt
so anyways jack uh basically says cool
this is a nft called fame and what fame
is
it will be the number one priced uh
piece of artwork in a digital artwork in
the world
right so he prices it above the people i
wasn't
i wasn't referring to this i was
referring to what he did last
i didn't even see this this is crazy
today last
last week what he did was he he wrote
he did an nft and it says here's the
difference between a uh
a jpeg and an nft and it just had a
verified it
he basically made a tweet and then he
sold that tweet for like
150 000 right which i thought was crazy
this is way crazier yeah because it's
crazier because
it might work exactly so okay so let's
walk through this if you're jack
why i'll tell you why do this and why it
might actually work why do this well
um if nothing else this is just a great
way to
drive attention uh press and um
and just do something that's bold right
so pricing you know pricing a piece of
your artwork for 77 million dollars it
doesn't even mean
it doesn't even matter if somebody buys
it just pricing it for 77 million
dollars
is uh is already gonna put you on the
map the second thing is
this might be a you know let's say take
the three outcomes
somebody actually buys it for 77 million
dollars right
um there's been crypto punks now the the
number one crypto punk
sold for abraham you look this up how
much did that crypt the top crypto punk
sell for
i think it was like seven seven million
dollars something like that
people sold for 69 million so there is a
chance there is a maybe
five percent two percent chance that
this thing actually sells for 77 million
dollars which would be
incredible second thing this might be a
shoot for the stars you land on the moon
situation
uh yeah the crypto poke sold for seven
and a half million um
and the guy who bought it by the way
this is kind of cool i don't know how
you pronounce this but
the person who bought it his handle is
perugia or pervugias i don't know what
it is i'm not
in the art world but that's the same
that's an
homage basically that's the same name of
the guy who stole the mona lisa
which is what helped catapult the mona
lisa to fame was when it was stolen
um and that was like part of the part of
what made the mona lisa even more
remarkable and
more valuable now most valuable piece of
artwork in the world
um and so so okay so by the way
great usage of the word homage yeah
thank you
um we're trying to class it over here so
all right so so he might not sell it for
77 million but even if it sells for 1.7
million
that's 1.7 million dollars that he just
you know manufactured through his own
creativity
and you know and probably i would bet
you like four days of effort
um i got i have chills looking at this
tweet that he put out
the reason why this is so crazy is it
might work
someone might be crazy enough to do this
right he basically has a no loss
situation and because
jack's brand is because he is
authentic he is um not kind of like a
you know quick flash in the pan trying
to make a quick quick dollar
like he's literally almost like you know
he's more of an artist really than he is
like anything else
and so he's been doing this for a while
he's been creating daily content he's
been building up a following and
so just like people did that people did
people did a new piece of art every day
for 10 years
and so it's like you know he's an
overnight success 10 years in the making
and i think jack's very similar so i see
jack having a no lose situation
and this is nfts are a thing that
basically fits his skill set
and so like there's a lot of reasons
people kind of [__] on nfts right now
one is that it's
overvalued it's a bubble what do you
really own look i can just screenshot
and boom i own the thing too
you know like there's a bunch of ways
you can make fun of this well one of the
good things that came out of this is
that
um you know in most of these these like
kind of hype cycles
it's the suits on wall street that get
rich this time at least it's starving
artists that get rich
and so you know at the very worst even
if the whole thing comes crashing at
least a few artists got paid
and you know who could be really too mad
at that i i can't so
so i think this is kind of like an
amazing thing jack's doing this boggles
my mind should we ask him to come on do
you want jack to come on yeah we should
for sure
are you friends with him yeah all right
not as close as you guys but yeah
we're we're close you should mention we
should leave you hops on today
um just be like you free to come talk
about your fame thing for for five
minutes let's see if he hops on at the
end of this
all right i just texted him all right
we'll we'll come
we'll come back to that uh [__] crazy
i uh yeah i almost have chills talking
about it
would it be weird going to a different
topic or do you want to stay on
nfts and stuff like that um we can do
whatever you want
is everything less is everything less
exciting
well i think it's going to go two ways
it's going to be if i'm listening to
this
and i'm most people who are listening to
this are kind of like not
as knee-deep into this world as we are
and and we're still like just kind of
dabbling and so the average person is
probably not
you know familiar with all these things
definitely not taking action and
definitely not getting rich all
these things so there's i think it's
going to be kind of polarizing some
people are going to think oh wow this is
really cool i should go check this out
and learn more about this
some people are like this is so stupid i
think this is all just like you know a
giant carnival game that you know some
kind of ponzi scheme that i don't want
to hear more about so
i don't know it's probably polarizing
let me move let's do a different one
um let's do a different one and we'll
only spend about 10 minutes on it and
then we're probably going to come back
to this
all right i actually want to come back
to this i want to come back to big cloud
i want to talk come back to angel
investing
okay um okay but someone i i tweeted out
that i'm gonna start a youtube channel
and someone
said you should talk about your research
process and that's a really hard thing
to talk about but i want to bring up one
one topic uh of my research process as
well as one interesting thing that i
found
so what i like to do is i like to find
out
who um is buying different parts of real
estate or different real estate so i go
to the realdeal.com and there's this one
segment called yolanda says
it's like this fake author named yolanda
he goes i heard a rumor
that this person's buying a house the
owner is this this and this yolanda
hears that
um they're gonna offer this much money i
have no idea jolan is a fake person
right it's just like a blog
a blog website gossip blog yeah for real
estate
mostly in new york and la though so
they're kind of famous famous e-purse
people doing it
and what i love to do is find out who
who's buying the real estate
and then i go and research them and the
reason why is one of the best ways to
figure out if someone's actually wealthy
or not
is by the real estate holdings that they
own that's one of the few things that
it's really hard to fake i mean you
could fake it but
if someone has bought a 20 million home
the likelihood that they're worth 100
million
plus is incredibly high um you know it's
hard to like [__] that right and so
real estate holdings is one of the best
way to get an indicator of someone's
wealth
or it's a great way not the best way but
it's a great way and i found one that
interested me a ton this guy's name was
brian carringer and he
uh bought a house in malibu in 2019 for
20 million dollars i hadn't heard brian
i know a lot of internet entrepreneurs
um
i hadn't heard of them so i researched
them and this is the guy who started
dictionary.com kind of a crazy
thing when you think about it because
who really thinks of
dictionary dictionary.com so in the
1990s this guy started
uh in 1995 he started a business called
lexico publishing and lexico publishing
owned the
thesaurus.com and dictionary.com and he
bootstrapped it and he grew and he sold
it in 2005 to iac
for a hundred million dollars and then
uh
two years ago iac sold dictionary.com to
dan gilbert you know dan gilbert of
quicken loans yep
he sold dictionary.com for uh or they
sell dictionary.com for 100 million
dollars so they they didn't do
a very good job with it but
dictionary.com gets around 40
dictionary.com and thesaurus.com gets
around
40 million uniques a month and does
about 20 million in revenue and they
have
barely any employees i i believe dozens
of employees it's incredibly fascinating
because
this is what i call how do they make
money it's just adsense or is there
something else just ads
all it is is ads and it's an incredibly
interesting company because it's one of
the things that i call
a for it you can let's call it i call it
a forgotten property
like just things that you forget that
even exist but just quietly make money
and are quite repeatable they're not
like necessarily sexy
um it's like the sweaty startup of
internet yeah yeah you know if
sweaty startup means a lot landscaping
business this is kind of like that for
the internet sure um
and but they've done a really good job
of staying relevant so they do a word of
the day
which people like particularly love like
it's a huge email list of we just get
the word of the day
they also do a word of a year word of
the word uh
of the year so when donald trump was
president in 2016 i think the word of
the year was xenophobic
because a lot of people were searching
what xenophobic means right uh
this past year in 2020 it was pandemic
and it was it's almost like a recap of
the year
and it's actually kind of culturally
relevant and also what they do is when
someone like kendall gender or kylie
jenner whatever the woman is who
is quote self-made they they'll do funny
stuff
like they'll tweet the definition
they'll retweet a tweet of her
calling herself self-made and they'll
they'll say actually the definition of
self
self-made is success unaided
or something like that like they like
they're pretty snarky i find this to be
incredibly interesting
um because it's something i didn't think
about and
that's kind of cool yeah you went from
100 to zero real quick there at the end
yeah uh okay so we actually had a friend
who was looking at buying dictionary.com
you know about this
no we had a friend that was looking at
buying dictionary.com
and merging it with another business i
can't remember the name of it now
urbandictionary.com is another big one
that one gets about 40 or 50 million
uniques a month
and who owns that wait uh just a guy a
guy in san francisco
aaron peckham so there's a similar uh
and you wrote another one on here that
that's similar to me which
is chess.com and so yeah i don't know as
much about it as you do so fill in the
gaps but i was
looking at it i was like oh man
chess.com is a great domain
uh chess is this kind of like very quiet
you know just like super sticky you know
just relevant it's a classic game right
it's just been relevant for so long
and then with queen's gambit it got like
way more popular recently
there's all these crazy charts spiking
the trends of people searching for chess
chess boards check how
to get good at chess like what is
queen's gambit how do you do a queens
gambit
all those things and so it had they have
200 employees
i bet you it's worth if you told me
i heard a rumor they're thinking about
selling and i would bet it would be
worth a quarter of a billion dollars
exactly that's that's what i was going
to say they have a huge amount of
traffic what's their traffic monthly
it's uh
i don't i'll look it up but they have
around 50 million registered users
right and they're not just like it's not
flyby traffic like dictionary.com
thesource.com they're going to have
a lot more traffic but it's going to be
fly by 200 200 million
monthly uniques according to similar web
most of which is direct
incredible right and so 200 million they
make money way
more though do you know how they make
money no i well i can guess tell me if
i'm right so i would guess that
basically they sell
some kind of you know course tutorial a
way to get better at chess
do they do that yeah and so you can meet
with coaches and you can pay coaches
money right
can they do they also have some kind of
like premium pro membership where you
get matched with better people and your
stats get saved and something like that
yep yep okay so so dead simple business
model
around a classic game that nobody owns
the ip to right it's not like saying
um monopoly well you can't do monopoly
somebody owns monopoly
you know i don't know who hasbro or
whoever owns monopoly
you can do it with chess and this is one
of the reasons why we talked about
religion as a really interesting
fun uh you know fundamental or like base
layer for any business because nobody
owns religion
but it's a highly recognized brand with
super high affinity
so i love businesses that are you know
like prey the app that's you know
basically calm for
for christianity or there's versions of
this for the muslim religion
and so i love religion as one of the
primary substrates because you have a
billion people who know about it
but uh nobody owns the ip so you can use
the ip
and so what what what was our friend
gonna do who who
i wonder who our friend is so i don't
remember exactly i don't know how much
we could really talk about it but they
were gonna basically buy two properties
at the same time dictionary.com and one
other one
and because they were like look
dictionary.com gets a ton of traffic but
it's not so sticky of a service it
doesn't really
have a great monetization potential it's
just display
display ads and then this other thing is
a great business model
and has um uh you know has great
stickiness
and maybe we merged the two like let's
just okay here's a hypothetical i don't
know if this is exactly what they said
but
if you're grammarly would you pay for
would you go buy dictionary.com and
thesaurus right because you're going to
go get 50 60 million people coming to
look up words and find out what words
mean and you can say hey by the way
if you you know if you ever feel like
you want to sharpen up with this maybe
you should uh
install grammarly which is a great way
to write you know choose better vocab
write write perfect grammar and
become a better writer right like they
have a business model attached to it
that that that makes sense and so i
wonder if there were other things like
that
maybe i would if i was grammarly i would
maybe buy dictionary.com
um i just thought it was interesting
because you don't really think about
this another one that i've been i'm
going to do research on
is easyjiff.com do you know that i know
that one yes i actually
so i have a slack channel called buyouts
in my slack
and uh i just have my slack with ben and
we have a slack of buyouts which is
basically
company uh websites that i think would
be awesome to buy easy jif was the first
one i ever put in that
that channel because i was like oh my
god i love this i love this simple tool
that gets a ton of traffic it's zero to
no maintenance
and uh and it makes money you know
remove.bg is another one like that
uh where you can just remove the
background of a photo and then you pay
for credits
so it's like you don't need to know
photoshop to remove the background of a
photo
and i just think that's genius so
easyjiff.com it's the letters e the
letter z
and then jiffgif.com eight million
uniques a month you go
there and you upload a uh video and it
turns it into a gif
uh i was doing research on it looks like
the guy it looks like it's only one uh
a small team a couple people um made in
latvia
uh uh lots
if i'm dictionary.com uh one thing that
they should do is they should take a
page out of the new york times playbook
so
i don't know if you've you probably have
because you're in the you know you're in
media you care about the stuff but most
people
aren't aware of how new york times
really makes money what it what its
business looks like today
and a pretty large part of their
business i i haven't done the research
because it's off top of my head but
very large i know tens of millions of
dollars a year i believe comes from
their games division particularly one
game
crossword and so um i play this game
every single day the new york times mini
crossword
it is uh literally a two-minute game
that like kind of stimulates the brain
and it's fun to do and it requires like
no kind of hand-eye coordination type of
thing
and it's not you can't get super
addicted to it because it's like one a
day
um so the mini crossword is like they
took the crossword which is a big part
of the papers
okay now the paper's all digital how do
we make a digital version of the
crossword
and then they made it mini so that it's
actually like simpler for the average
person to do
you can like pretty much always win and
um super fun game and so the
i don't know what the the other revenue
numbers of crossword and in the game
so keep on going so if i'm
dictionary.com that's you know whoever's
the ceo of dictionary.com
hey free idea that i think would
generate probably eight to ten million
dollars a year
you should come out with your take all
these popular uh games like
word scramble or mini crossword
or um you know all these different
little word word puzzle games that are
very popular in the app store
and they have trouble with distribution
good games trouble with distribution
all you need to do is reskin that as the
dictionary.com game
and put it as a pop-up for people coming
to the site to hey
download this fun game and uh you know
even if you're converting you know half
a percent of your traffic
to this thing you're gonna end up
driving a lot of revenue because this
game is
these games work and all they need is
distribution and maybe people who come
to diction.com or they subscribe to the
word of the day email
like i think they would like to play
these little word games they're very
popular even my mom plays these little
word scramble games okay so uh
some information on new york times new
york times is a publicly traded company
so this is where i'm getting some of the
numbers but i don't always break out the
revenue by segment so i'm doing a little
bit of guesstimation but i would bet i'm
right within
10 to 20 percent um so in 2020
new york times said they had 600 000
people paying for the crossword puzzle
only just crossword puzzle
that was in 2020 2020 was a huge year
for
uh subscribe subscription remember
everything's actually yeah
everything doubles but let's just round
that up to eight hundred thousand for
six hundred thousand
so eight hundred thousand i believe it
cost six dollars and ninety five cents a
month for a crosswind puzzle but so
let's run that up to seven dollars so
seven dollars times
eight hundred thousand we're looking at
5.6 million dollars a month
60 million or uh 67 million dollars a
year in subscription revenue
only from crossfit puzzles right that's
it that's just the crossfit puzzle
division right
[__] crazy right right exactly uh and
they're
like i read an article recently uh where
the guy was like you know someone from
the new york times was like yeah we're
quadrupling down on games
games exploded during kovid crossword is
already an amazing franchise for us
the next they have another game i forgot
what it is but they have like you know a
few staple games that are like these
classics
and they're like you know we're we're
actually a games company
the guys literally said that he goes you
know we we don't just you know just put
the game the same exact game on a phone
we like kind of reinvent it so that it's
like even more fun on your phone we try
to like put a twist on the game we're
not just going to come out with
you know the classic you know like for
example 2048 if you ever played that
little numbers game
where you slide the tiles and it like
you know it adds up to 2048
um the game's awesome and so new york
times can come out with a version of
which is like um you know their own
twist on the game so i found that to be
pretty interesting and that's what i
would do if i was dictionary.com
um so in this segment the takeaway
should be learn about
real estate and read the real deal and
google all the entrepreneurs
and the reason why you do that is you're
going to discover stuff like dictionary
thesaurus.com and you're eventually
going to learn about
crossfit puzzles and the reason why this
is important what we're discussing is
just interesting
stuff but the reason why this is all
important
is we are showing that you can make a
killing a [__] killing hundreds of
millions of dollars to the point where
you're buying a 20 million dollar home
on the beachfront of
malibu more than most celebrities will
ever
be able to afford and you're doing it by
building something that
you're just like it starts as like a
silly thing that you never would have
thought
could actually become this big and when
you see this stuff it actually inspires
you
and or at least it inspires me knowing
that like i can turn
something silly into something
profitable and that's a badass that is
awesome
just knowing that that's possible it is
cool it's kind of like
why does everyone why did five people
break the four minute mile in the same
year
when previously no one had done it it's
because when you see what's possible it
it it pushes the boundary and it and it
shows you what you can do
that's neat to me so we should also say
uh so two things
that i took away from that you are
really good at
figuring out uh like you sniff out these
little interesting stories because you
just think
who's that guy how does he drive that
car how much is that car yeah
how'd you get that money right and
actually there's a famous tick tock
channel that just does
only this i don't know if you used to
but he goes up to people getting out of
like lamborghinis or like you know like
just killer cars and just be like hey
man uh what do you do for a living
and the guy's like what and he just said
yo well what do you do for a living i
just i'm curious
you guys like i'm in real estate real
estate cool man and he just leaves right
listen that's it yeah it kind of bothers
them for a second and then you know the
person will be like you know
i'm a cannabis entrepreneur i'm uh you
know i'm a hedge fund guy i uh
i'm a youtuber i'm a whatever right well
uh the joke of that channel is the
people say one of two things
the women say i'm a wife yeah and they
like are joking
and then they also or they'll say i sell
drugs right right exactly
and then they like zoom away um and so
so i love that channel at first i think
that's just like a really simple fun
idea for a tick tock channel and then um
but but there is some like kind of merit
to that and it's really helped me in
life which is basically anytime you see
somebody who's got an interesting
lifestyle
i like to figure out two things one is
is your whole day like this what's your
day like
what do you do how do you do that and i
like to see how people architect their
life right like
and that sort of like it's like like you
said about the four minute mile it opens
your mind to what's possible so recently
i got this like a private chef person
who's like making meals for me they
don't
they don't come to my house they don't
make food in my house but it's like a
delivery service meal prep service
but let's call it a private chef right
because it's not doordash it's somebody
who's
giving me a menu or giving feedback yeah
you're doing the same because i'm doing
it you know trying to be fit you're
trying to do this for the same reason
you want to eat healthier and
hey if you can afford it that's a
convenient way to do it right where you
know you got the the p word privilege to
be able to do it
and so uh the reason i think that's even
possible or i realized that was because
the investor in my last company he had a
private chef that was like a former
michelin star
chef at a restaurant this guy elgin
amazing chef who
was like would be in his house and he
would make you know lunch and dinner for
them every single night
and i was like whoa i didn't even
realize people have that and it's not
that oh
you know i want that but it's i didn't
even realize that's a possibility of a
lifestyle that you could have it is a
upgraded part of your life
and so there's all these little examples
i've i've had in my life of like
like i have a cousin who has like a
virtual assistant in the philippines
and i asked him how do you do what do
you do with that how do you set it up
how did you find the right person right
just get real curious about different
people's lifestyles and how they
architect how they design their life
and you kind of you can pick and choose
from there what works for you what you
want
out of your life the second thing is why
did the guy behind dictionary.com
like make it work right because it's
like kind of a simple idea well he was
early to a platform right so to get the
domain
dictionary.com you couldn't do that
today but you could do it when the web
was early and not everybody believed
which is a perfect segue back to
bitcloud
new platforms by the way speaking of big
clout uh i texted jack while we were
talking he's going to be joining any
second now
oh perfect um so we brought this up on
the last podcast because ryan
beagleman came on a friend of ours came
on and was like dude
i haven't had this much fun on a product
since like the early days of facebook
i'm obsessed with this thing and he was
asking us like
are you going to use it are you going to
claim your account so if you missed that
episode let me just give you the like 10
seconds of what this is
uh imagine you know if if like robin
hood and twitter had a baby
so it's basically a stock market for
people so you go on the app
bigcloud.com and you just see all these
people
and you can buy instead of just
following them or just liking their
content you can actually
buy into their stock essentially you can
buy their crater coins
and so you could buy their coins and
every time you buy the price goes up and
every time you sell the price goes down
and so it's kind of like a stock market
for people's reputations
and um and so when we did the pod my my
coin was
about 1500 at the time while we were
recording it
and ryan was like my fourth biggest
holder he had bought up a bunch and he
was like are you gonna use this thing or
not i said
sure i'll give it a try and i'll see
what happens of course dude yeah you
know like
there's guys who take like like my
friend jack
takes every vitamin if you're like hey i
have this vitamin boom done take it
right like he takes every vitamin or he
takes every type of supplement you could
ever
you are like that with bitcoin or any
type of like
this isn't bad but like schemes so it's
like hey there's this thing called the
big cloud okay hang on yep i just
uploaded hundreds of thousands of
the hundreds of thousands and i'm in
that is you you you tried
everything i learned i learned from you
well i don't think it's all the best but
i do at the beginning
you know at the beginning it makes sense
to be optimistic when everybody else
is uh you know pessimistic or skeptical
uh you're like you fall
to this is the greatest thing i've ever
seen that's your default
no no my default is i'm game to try it
and then if it starts to have some merit
i'm like
okay you know what's really cool about
this x y and z
even if a b and c but that's not how
people perceive it i had people message
me
after our thing saying like why the hell
is sean
uh pumping this big club thing it's a
ponzi scheme and i was like i don't know
he likes it that's just right that's his
opinion he likes it
but they were mad at they were mad at me
because we were promoting this and i was
like i don't know
so let me explain so we have two friends
so you have one of your best buddies is
jack smith
um and jack he came on the podcast we
did an episode with him
back when this was an interview show and
i asked him i said well how did you
create this bungle thing that now sold
for i know 750 million dollars or
something like that
and the root of his thing was i try
every platform early
as soon as something comes out i want to
try it and in fact yes if you go on big
cloud
jack smith owns two cents of my my coin
oh he was there before me of course he
was right
on product he became the number one
power user as soon as product hunt came
out he used it every single day
with nfts and collectibles um he's like
the number one power user on all these
different platforms for digital
for for for fractional ownership and
collective yeah on uh rally road he's
the number one
buyer exactly and um and so that's what
jack does and
it's not that all of these will work
it's that you only need
one to work for it to pay off big right
if you were early in twitter
uh you know even just as a user you
would have a big following if you were
early as an investor in any of these
companies
if they hit it gets very big so that was
the first kind of huh i noticed that
from jack
then i saw then i was talking to my
friend fer khan he's the cto and was
co-founder of my previous company
probably the best kind of technology guy
i know and
furcon's always dabbling so he was the
one telling me about bitcoin and
ethereum before anybody else
before and i didn't listen to him i
didn't buy and he was just buying like
he put like five grand into ethereum in
the ico or something like that you know
like
and so you know the ico of ethereum was
17 cents and now
it sells now every ether is is uh
1700 right so you can see the type of
appreciation you get when one of these
hits
and he's had you know for every one that
one ether that hits big like that
he has you know maybe 50 or 100 things
that don't fully pan out like for
example he's huge on vr
he bought me an oculus i was like dude
let's play vr poker together let's try
vr
and like vr hasn't hit in a big way yet
and he spent you know
thousands of dollars on vr he spent you
know hundreds of hours building in vr
and so far that's yielded nothing but i
asked him what's what's your deal with
this is it because you like
am i dumb i don't think vr is big you
you seem to be all over he goes no
what i do is anytime there's an
interesting technology
i'm just curious about it and therefore
i'm liking the first 10 000 people
that really understand every new
technology and he's like
because of that one of those
technologies is going to be big so right
now for example he's super into vertical
farming
and like hydroponic farming and he's
just like all about indoor farming all
about vertical farming and like
so he's we have this one hour a week
called the cool [__] hour
where i just sit back on zoom and he
just kind of shows me the cool [__] he's
been trying out
this week and this week was all about
vertical farming and it blew my mind i
didn't know anything about it
and he was telling me all the reasons
it's awesome why is this just not an
episode that we do
it should it really should be because
it's so good it's kind of my edge right
now because he tells me about [__] and
then i go
take action on it and like he's even
earlier than me so he gets more upside
but i'm still very early just by being
buddies with this guy so anyway that's a
long way of saying
it in technology it pays to be
optimistic
it pays to be an early adopter if you're
willing to look stupid sometimes by
by putting some time or money into
things that fail
you you will net out way way ahead just
by being early into a bunch of
interesting things
at the very least you learn um but at
the most
one of these hits and then you gain a
bunch of like you build a big network
there or you make a bunch of money
because you invested in it
so anyways that's that's my overall
philosophy i totally see the people who
are like bitcloud is dumb
this is a scam this is a sham this is
you know
this will never work hey i think there's
merits to all those arguments but from
my opinion i just thought
this sounds interesting sounds very
different than anything else that's out
there
i tried it and i immediately liked it so
the first 24 hours i was hooked
by the second 24 hours i had put a
hundred thousand dollars into the
platform
you know don't tell my wife so right now
my
um you is a
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
dollars it's a lot of money
yeah so let me tell you why
it is a little bigger thing right now my
thing is uh my
market cap on here is it goes 170 to 200
i sold some of my stuff and a guy wired
or um
sent me money on coinbase uh ten
thousand dollars right
i'm like i think this is silly but like
i told you this is silly and you're
still gonna give me money okay fine i'll
take it
i sold some of mine yeah you sold some
errors i have not sold any of mine
uh and instead i actually invested money
into the platform or bought a bunch of
people's coins including yours
and so um so i own a bunch of coins for
all these different people that i think
might appreciate and so
i would say there is still a i would say
in the long run
this working in the long run i think
there's like a less than two percent
chance this works in the long run
if it does work my hundred thousand
dollars is going to be worth tens of
millions of dollars
but that's the that's the long run um
two percent case
okay well i wouldn't put up a hundred
grand for a two percent win
because i actually have a second way to
win in this case which is that
i have now been an early adopter of
basically every crypto thing
over the last i don't know five six
years and some of them are dumb some of
them work whatever
and what i've seen is that anytime a
kind of new exciting disruptive idea
comes out whether it's icos or nfts or
whatever pick your favorite acronym
there's like a hype cycle that takes
place
there's the people who are there's the
people who make it that's the people who
buy in at the beginning and get get
access and then there's like
a bunch of crypto enthusiasts who are
believers in the general
like innovation space of crypto that
then say oh cool this sounds fun i want
to go try it and that's happening right
now with nfts like we talked about our
friend
jack who's selling a bunch of nfts for
you know hundreds of thousands if not
millions of dollars
it's because there are crypto
enthusiasts who say nfts are really cool
i want to invest in that the crypto
enthusiasts
are not many of them hate big clout uh
yeah sure
some many many if there's crypto
enthusiast is not one group of people
it's broken up into like
what's called bitcoin maximum list they
don't want to talk about anything except
for bitcoin
and they don't want to they they want to
invest 100 into bitcoin then there's
ethereum people who are like all about
ethereum then there's people who are
just
just trying to degenerately gamble
across all the different like different
crypto projects that exist
i'm talking about more about them the
gamblers because i understand the game
more money
have you made more money off bitcoin
than you have selling your company
no that'd be cool if you did it would
have been sweet
i think in the long run i will but uh as
of now no
but you know if you project forward five
years i would
almost certainly my crypto holdings will
be worth more than what i sold the
company for when i got out of the sale
do you think that what percentage of
your net worth do you have a crypto
so i i tweeted out that i was moving 25
into of my net worth into bitco into
bitcoin and not just like not just
liquid net worth just
net worth i ended up getting about 20 in
but the price kept rising as i was doing
it um
so my my overall my average buy price is
about eleven thousand dollars
per bitcoin um but anyways
my my holdings now are like i don't know
almost fifty percent of my net worth
just because
crypto has appreciated so i didn't put
in as much as i said i was going to it
was a little bit less
but it appreciated so now it makes up
more and i didn't sell
i didn't like sell to rebalance let's
put it that way
that's crazy so anyways the thing i want
to tell you about is
so that's my general my my let's let's
play out three scenarios
scenario one uh let's say with big clout
this is a
a scam i don't believe it's a scam given
that they have
backers and investors like andres and
horowitz and sequoia
chamoth coin you know coinbase capital
the winklevoss
like basically like everybody who's
legit in the technology slash crypto
space like
these are tier one names that are
invested in this thing i don't think
it's a scam it's definitely not a scam
in the sense of that's like it's
malicious people right so that's that's
like one one thing that does happen in
the crypto world people take your money
and they [__] run away
right that is literally that has
literally happened so i don't think it's
that
um and i'll bucket in you know one of
the big criticisms is you can't withdraw
your money yeah you have a huge amount
of value in there but you can't withdraw
yet
i would bucket that into the scam
argument like if you think they'll never
allow you to withdraw i think that's
silly that would be a scam then after
that podcast i kind of understood what
the heck big clout was
which is it's basically a social network
where you can bet on the people who are
gonna
you know and their reputation and so as
a
as a as a participant you could say okay
instead of just following sam if i think
sam is awesome and sam's going to only
get more popular over time
i can actually invest in sam which is a
little bit different than like
patreon or sub stack where it's like
i'll pay you for your [__]
that's different that's like okay do i
want to buy this content or not instead
this
is i'm a believer in you and so like
back to that thousand true fans concept
it's like if i'm a believer in you i can
invest in you
and as more people realize that you're
the [__]
um your price will continue to go up and
i will actually i'll go up with you
my my stock and you will appreciate so i
can actually make money
being a curator being somebody who um
who recognizes talent before
others do who recognizes reputations
that are on the rise
so i think that's really cool that's a
new thing you couldn't do that before
if i was an early user of snapchat or
like twitter or
facebook or whatever it was cool but
like i didn't actually gain anything
from it financially
if i discovered jack you know you said
you met jack when jack had a kind of
smaller following
you didn't gain financially from jack's
following growing
and so i think that's a new thing that
that that's a really cool mechanic
now on the other side let's say you're
let's say you're the creator let's say
you're jack
you can basically go on and say cool you
know what
um i'm like a little mini warren buffett
i want to have my berkshire hathaway
summit my my shareholder meeting so you
can basically say cool for my top 25
coin holders
um i will meet with you personally and
you know in a zoom or in person
somewhere
um and that's a privilege you get by
being one of my top shareholders
or i can say hey i'm gonna produce some
premium content and instead of having to
set up a whole different app like
substance or patreon or
or something else like you just say
great if you own over 10 of my coin you
get this thing
um and so it gives people a way to not
just buy the content
but to be a long-term holder of you and
i think that's really cool too as a
creator
and so so you're in your market cap
right now it's like six hundred thousand
dollars
how did it did it get that high because
you bought your own stuff or
i've only bought net one coin of mine um
so
why are people buying you or how are
they even hearing it i heard about it on
the pod i think so i think that was one
thing but then otherwise there's just
people hearing about big cloud because a
whole bunch of people join right like so
even just in our little network right um
andrew wilkinson joined two days ago and
you know he's a super legit person and
he tweeted out today
i woke up at five in the morning
thinking about big clouds and he's like
you know and not just all good things
right he said like
the design kind of sucks i kind of hate
the name i wish it didn't feel so shady
because the way they're doing this this
and this
but here's some things that like the
mind virus has infected him where it's
like
wait this does open up pandora's box of
a whole bunch of new
capabilities and things that you just
kind of kind of couldn't do before
and definitely couldn't do in a platform
that had any legs and this has legs
about 170 million dollars has been
deposited onto this
most of that is from their institutional
backers like andrews and horowitz and
sequoia and those other guys um but
but the rest has been you know maybe
eight to ten million dollars has come in
from
from users who are buying into the
platform uh the cto of hubspot darmesh
he's on there every day me and him are
chatting on there all the time because
he's like he's posting like you know
he's a daily user of this thing
because i think it's a cool new
technology cool app and he's playing
with it he bought money
he he bought my stuff exactly and so uh
i've had a lot of fun
basically speculating on people buying a
bunch of people's coins and i think
i think those people are awesome or
undervalued so for example i'll give
you an example i saw this guy on big
clout and he was posting a bunch of
analysis so he's like
exploring the blockchain and he's he
says look because this is built on the
blockchain it's all public
you know if i go to facebook i can't
tell you how many daily active users
facebook has
they have to disclose that information
for me to know it but with things
built on the blockchain you just see it
and so um
so this guy's posting like look here's
how many new people signed up today
here's how many
posts there's been and so you can see
like how much engagement this thing has
or if
it starts to fade you'll be able to see
it fade so i bought this i bought a [__]
ton of this guy's coin i bought ten
thousand dollars of this analyst
coin because this guy was super low
priced because nobody knows who the heck
this guy is
but i knew that if if there are people
who are power users of the platform
they're enthusiastic about big clout
they're going to love all the
information the 24 7 news cycle about
big cloud
they're going to love this guy's
analysis because it's not easy to do
it's not easy to go on the blockchain
and figure this stuff out
so i thought oh if this guy's if this
guy's gonna put reports up every day
he's gonna get popular and so already
i've doubled my money on this guy just
because
um i was able to like have a strategy
have a a skilled
gamble as what i'll call it right same
reason i love poker
same reason i like investing in startups
and the stock market
is because there is definitely this like
deep itch scratches of like trying to
put in money and triple it and make more
money
um combined with some skill there is a
strategy to it it's not just a slot
machine where you just pull the lever
and you hope for the best
so for for whatever reason for some
combination of reasons this [__] is so
addictive to me and maybe this will fade
i'm only three or four days in
but man i've used the hell out of this
thing in three or four days and i don't
know what's gonna happen i've only known
it for three or four days but
my life this is my vocation i found it
that's what i hear from you
well you hear what you want to hear i
didn't say that what i said was
i've had an amazing three or four days
and this might fade um
but i view it as a kind of asymmetric
bet
if this one if it fails i lose one i
lose one times my money
if this succeeds i'm going to make more
than 10 times my money and so
that's why it's a good bit for me
speaking of betting on people jack we
were talking about you earlier basically
uh sean i didn't know so basically we
gave your background we said that you
and celia lived in a shitty apartment
a little studio five 450 square foot
studio or something like that and brooke
tried to make it sound like slumdog
millionaire he was like he's like you
know
they shared one ramen noodle each and
yeah
jack was that right was it 400 something
square feet
450. in bad neighborhood crown heights
that's right yeah i mean it was
it was all right um
and and uh basically started an agency
it was only going okay not going that
great
and then like over the last 18 24 months
you've just knocked it out the park yada
yada
i didn't realize until sean said it when
he said do you see what jack did it's
crazy i thought he meant
you selling one nft for like a hundred
grand
i didn't or however much you sold that
like what's the difference between a
jpeg and an nft thing
i didn't see that you have one for 76
million dollars
just put it up this morning do you think
that's gonna work look at this
i love it okay so jack can you tell us
about the 77 million dollar one what's
the thinking behind that
and then just in general what's the nft
experience been like
it's kind of mind-blowing yeah i think
um interestingly enough
this text message that got me on this
podcast
is uh kind of uh evidence for the
strategy behind
the 77 million 77 million dollar nft
which
the thesis is um it's rounded up
from the highest bid on that b pool
collage so that was 69.3 and obviously
tracks to the
price of ethereum but anybody who would
bid on this would be
you know the owner of the most expensive
nft in the world
um so you know part press play
commentary on the world of nft's
artistic statement uh i
have very very very you know
the the idea of that selling is
obviously absolutely ludicrous
but the fact that you can do something
like that without permission and
make a statement like that i think is
like that's that's
the uh the intent behind the the piece
itself and the nft space like the last
three
pieces that i've been working on the
last three pieces i've launched have
been sort of a
commentary on the world of nft so the
first one sam talked about it's like
what's the difference between
a jpeg and an nft i put that image on
twitter and
you got a great response someone
commented and said you should make this
an nft
let's just say no more made in nft and
auctioned it
and then the second one uh just finished
today there's like a
comment on the idea of non-fungibility
right so anybody can save this jpeg
but what we're really talking about here
is like this mimetic
status game that's all these different
incentives coming together to
you know some people are buying these
because they love them some people are
buying them in the same way that
they're betting on a creator like a big
clout uh the same thesis behind a big
clout you
buy this thing and you assume this
person is going to keep creating for
years and maybe they emerge
at the top of the space and then your
investment increases in value
um i think there's a lot of parallels
with what you're talking about with
bitcoin
it's it visualize value sort of
was almost a layer on top of the
business i was operating so i was making
these graphics
to you know create things that would get
people's attention to then put something
else in front of them and be like hey
here's
this thing so like my background is
marketing and advertising and that's
how that works right you make stuff to
get people to look at other stuff
but now there's like this convergence of
you can get paid directly for the things
you make
which is completely different right i
think
you know patreon what do you think the
odds are that someone's gonna buy this
i mean impossible to say 0.00
why no well what's happened since since
you put it up this morning no
are people bidding on it can you can you
bid below that ass no no
so you have to enter that it's all or
nothing yeah
yeah okay can you see any of the
activity of like
traffic to it twitter well that's the
only place i would have
data and what's your what's your people
would visit
a few thousand i think is this like so
far
and i think it's like it's also an
inside joke as well right like you have
to have the context of the people thing
mario yep who sean i saw you saw that
tweet
he added this layer of context to it
which is like
the reason uh you know it's very minimal
in its execution but when you have that
additional context i think it's like
there's a light bulb moment that goes
off so
the thing i respect is that it's all or
nothing if you had done it where it's
like oh well
hey may not get 77 million but i'll take
you know 77 000.
well then it's sort of like okay he's
just you know it doesn't have the same
artistic balls that it takes to say no
this is the if we're either breaking the
record and this is the most valuable
piece of digital art in the world
oh we're not and it's a commentary on
the whole
madness of the situation it's like we're
either going all mad
or we're laughing about how mad this was
that we're not doing anything in between
i'm not this is not a
this is not some you know quick sale
here again another parallel with
bitcloud
it either goes off or it just uh you
know it just stays there forever as a
memory
right yeah as i that's why i tweeted i
said this is either going to be an
amazing investment
or amazing lesson learned for me and um
and and i mean that because
i i intentionally invested an amount of
money that would hurt
for me to lose it um like i would really
have to like lick my wounds if i lost
this amount of money because
it's not going to just go down by like
10 it's going to go down by percent
or it's gonna go up by like ten thousand
percent and so you know either way i'm
gonna learn something out of this whole
process it is so
polarized and clear and i had to write
down why am i doing this what do i
believe about this
and what and part of the why i'm doing
this wasn't just here's all the great
reasons to do this it was like
well you know i kind of sat on the
sideline at this other thing that i was
early on and i missed out on this big
wave and a bunch of my friends made a
bunch of money doing it
and so i'm kind of waiting for the next
one and like now that this one's here
i'm kind of over over compensating for
it
so i was really honest with myself about
what was what are the
psychological drivers and and i'll put
put two things together one is
one is that which is like here's the
dark side of why i'm doing this meaning
like
here's the not so great reasons but true
reasons that i feel motivated to do this
right my own psychology
put on a piece of paper the second thing
is
maybe this is um you guys have probably
all heard this i know jack you have for
sure sam you know the thing about the
four levels of luck
no because the four levels of luck i
forgot mark andreessen shared this from
somebody else and then neval shared it
and
that's how i heard it but basically it's
like there's
there's dumb luck or you're just you're
standing still and luck just hits you
upside the head
something really lucky you just have you
get struck by lightning right um
that's just dumb luck you did nothing
and something happened then there's like
the second level which is
you're moving around like crazy and
you're doing a bunch of [__] and then
doing a bunch of [__] you kick up a
bunch of dust you move a bunch of things
around
and actually you have a higher
percentage chance of colliding with luck
because you were taking so much action
right
and so that's kind of like you know um
uh you know the luck favors the bold
basically you took a bunch of action
therefore you're
more lucky than somebody who didn't then
there's a third one which is
luck favors the prepared mind which is
you're moving but you're also looking
and when you see something you
recognized luck before others
saw it and so i would say jack is a good
example of this which is he had the
artistic ability to create
really compelling visuals but he also
had the like
business brain and like kind of tech
savviness and was in the tech world
enough
to see nfts as this opportunity uh that
he could marry his two things together
and give it a try
and so that's where you recognize luck
for what it is
and then the fourth one is reputational
luck which is
you have built up such a big reputation
that luck finds you well that's where
some in some great company says sam we
would love to have you on board because
we've been reading your content for
years you're such an amazing copywriter
and we just think you could really help
us out with that
you know um and so boom luck came to
your doorstep
and that's that's sort of the analogy
that naval gave or whatever was like
someone finds a sunken treasure
and they come to you because you're
known as the world's best scuba diver
so to me this is like luck level three
um and maybe a little four but three in
that luck favors the prepared mind
so what i realized when i i looked back
at bitcoin and i said
i was being told by smart friends back
in 2013 2014 that bitcoin is amazing
and at first i took no action that cost
me you know
the price was i think 70 at the time so
i let it go from 70 to 700
and then i bought it at 700 and even
then i bought in such a small amount
that it wasn't gonna like change my life
either way i wasn't gonna care if i lost
i wasn't gonna be rich if i won
um and i i went and i looked back and i
said well why didn't i take more action
at that time right
let's let's do the hindsight game and
one thing i realized is that
in order to i i didn't bet on it because
i didn't have enough conviction i didn't
have enough conviction because i didn't
even understand what the heck it was
so part of that is i didn't take time to
understand it but the second was
bitcoin was one of those weird things
that you had to have two totally
different skill sets in order to
appreciate the
how great this thing is you had to be
really technologically sound
uh in your brain to even under even
understand it and be able to go buy the
thing or mind the thing
it took real tech savviness to do it at
that that time
the second thing was you had to really
understand macroeconomics and very few
people had that combination
and the people who did have become
billionaires and have been very wealthy
people now
but most people who had one or the other
or neither they didn't
they didn't benefit right so you need to
you needed to understand
that wow this solved the byzantine
generals problem
this is a computer science breakthrough
and now we can have trustless systems
without any central entity
but you also needed to understand that
hey the government prints all this money
and has this inflationary effect and the
reason that you know
and actually this thing that we all take
for granted the u.s dollar or currency
has really only been around in its
current form for i don't know 70-ish
years and
uh and you know before that we had gold
and before that we had shells and money
actually does evolve over time and maybe
this is the new form of money and here's
why
it's a more sound money than these other
things i'm familiar with
right so very few people had that
overlap i see the same thing happening
with bitcloud which is
on one hand you had to understand the
financial incentives
that this like the token economics or
crypto economics that exists
here what are all the incentives and why
would this thing go up
and when you if you understand the
crypto economics the token incentives
you're like holy [__] this is so well
designed
this is a very high likelihood of going
up if it going up a lot if it becomes a
thing
the other side is just understanding how
social networks start
and um when i saw that oh this is like
probably the most brilliant growth hack
i've ever seen these people who
whoever made this is very aggressive and
very smart they're aggressive
because they went and scraped twitter
and they put all of our profiles on
their website and said come buy their
coin
without anyone's permission that took a
level of aggression
and sort of like willing to operate in
the gray that most people wouldn't
really have
and then the smart thing was they said
well how do we make this network
really valuable well if we get really
valuable people on it how do we get
really valuable people on it
well let's do this let's go to really
legit investors so big name investors
that adds credibility let's go get
100 million dollars from them and then
let's invest that 100 million dollars
into the accounts of all the influential
twitter people and so when i went to the
website without ever having used the
damn thing
my account had 55 000 sitting in it
all i had to do was tweet it out and say
hey i'm using big cloud come use it with
me basically
right and i had to tweet that to my 120
000 followers
in order to claim this 50 thousand
dollars that was sitting in there this
like kind of imaginary fifty thousand
dollars i was sitting there
and um okay so that i was like that's
gonna work a lot of influencers are
gonna go see
a hundred thousand dollars sitting in
their account and they say all i gotta
do is tweet this thing out
like done like sam you think the thing's
[__] stupid but you did it anyways
because you were like [__] i got 35
grand sitting in here i'll take that
and jack how much money do you have
sitting in your thing uh about 150 i
think last time i looked at it
so 150 000 maybe is sitting in your
account and have you verified your
account yeah or claimed it no
do you plan to i'm still i don't know
man i'm getting text messages and phone
calls and being invited on podcasts to
talk about bitcloud so maybe i gotta do
it
yeah maybe you do and maybe you have a
pretty big [__] incentive to do it
which is that there's 150 grand sitting
there just for
just for tweeting the thing out and um
and so then you so then you go like
layers deep you say okay so they're
gonna tweet it out they're gonna
claim their money and then they have a
big following so then their people are
gonna say oh if jack says it i trust
jack and jack is
jack is using it then i should probably
use this thing they go on
and because there's no withdrawals right
now all the prices just go up
and so everybody's going to get all
these paper gains and then they're all
going to talk about how this is the
greatest thing since sliced bread cause
they're just making all this money on
here right like our friend ryan who came
on was like dude i'm making a killing on
this thing
and then other people are gonna say oh
[__] my friend's making a killing on
this thing i should go do that too i
don't want to miss the next bitcoin i
already i already missed bitcoin now i'm
gonna miss the next one
and they're going to get on and that's
going to drive the price even higher and
so
what i saw was that this thing was
brilliantly designed from kind of like a
game theory perspective
now let's take let's table like the
moral questions and like is this a ponzi
scheme
like there's a whole bunch of other
questions but i at the very minimum i
thought wow
this game is architected so that these
numbers are going to go up this is going
to have a hype cycle
very likely chance of having a hype
cycle and if it has the hype cycle
these things just like bitcoin bitcoin
is only valuable because everybody
believes in it now
and the more people believe in it the
more valuable it gets the more certain
its own success becomes
the same thing is true for any network
any social network too the more legit
people believe in it and want it to
succeed
um the more likely it is to succeed and
so then there's actually
a chance that this does become you know
a new a new wave of social networks so
anyways that's my whole
sorry i've i've known you for uh
since uh maybe eight years now it was
early on when i met you that you had
some type of it factor and that you were
at least
mildly smart what what big clout and
bitcoin has done for you
has basically like brought out all of
your confidence and all of your speech
giving abilities
now the whole high iq thing and if
you're right thing
tbd but your ability to convince people
that it's awesome
very very high i congratulate you on
your confidence
and your ability to persuade people i
think it's i think i think i think you
finally have come out of your shell
now all right the whole are you right
thing
well no we're gonna i keep saying the
thing which is there's a very low chance
that this succeeds in the long run if it
does
you're gonna get paid super handsomely
very similar to bitcoin back in 2013
and very similar to the hundreds of
other crypto projects that had the same
promise
and didn't pan out right so that's the
thing with low odds usually they don't
pan out
when they do you can get paid handsomely
there's a middle ground here where
if this goes through a hype cycle there
is a good chance that even if it doesn't
succeed in the long run in the short run
there's a bunch of money to be made that
is the degenerate gambler side
of me and many people anybody who is in
the into game stop
anybody who's you know going and trading
a lot of people have
fun speculating and trying to uh make
money and they're not necessarily trying
to be long-term holders so that's
situation two it's situation three is it
just flops it goes to zero there are all
three scenarios on the table
what i'm trying to say is the
probability is i'm not saying this is
likely or definitely going to succeed
what i'm saying is i find it super
interesting from a product point of view
how they made it
and i think there's a good chance it
goes through the hype cycle beyond that
i don't know so jack um
what what what does this mean to you
what what side are you on
i'm just sort of waiting for it to shake
out i guess i think the first time it
came
across my feed was like the ultimate
bear case
like you know this has broken the the
commandments of crypto therefore you
should not go anywhere
near it and my understanding of the like
mechanics of pre-mining and all of these
like i wasn't paying attention to the
ico cycle when it was happening years
ago so i just felt
pretty um you know unqualified to make a
bet on it and i think
to your point sean there's like
reputational risk in endorsing it too
before it gets to
a point of i don't know
some of the things that are left unsaid
or haven't been clarified are clarified
so
i'm on the sidelines for the time being
yeah i think that's smart i think that's
the risk i run which is
i think that when i say hey this is a
this is a gamble
you can lose all your money it's not
likely to succeed that there's that
there
could be some money to be made here's my
exact holdings i feel like
i'm disclosing everything and smart
adults are going to do with that what
they want
do your own research don't rely on me
and
come to your own conclusions i'm telling
you what i've come to thus far three
days in
and so i'm always like oh people will
get all that in reality all anyone's
gonna remember is dude you were super
excited about that thing and either i
look like a [__] genius
or i look like an idiot scam artist
that's the sad part about it is that
nobody's gonna remember any of the
nuance around how i was thinking about
it anybody just remember dude you
sounded so excited you said you put 100
grand in and either
you know that's why you're the hottest
things to slice bread if that becomes a
10 million
steak or it's gonna be i lost my life
savings how could you you told me this
was gonna work
and uh unfortunately um the way i wish
the world
the way i wish people listen to it is
not gonna be how people actually listen
to it as my guest
are you the biggest uh the biggest bit
clout bull in the world
sean ah not even close
like craig clemons uh who's you know
friend of ours been on the pod
um he was on it before us he's invested
i don't know how much money but he's
like the biggest whale you go to
anyone's account
he owns he owns like the majority of
their coin like he
he and he's like yeah i'm bullish um
like you know he could speak for himself
how he's thinking about the calculated
risk but like
you know he's got a huge stake and i'm
you know envious of how early he was on
and how
bullish he was early because it's
already he's got a lot of paper gains
let's put it that way
um as far as uh and then there's of
course a bunch of other people like
you know there's there's the big the the
the the whale guy
i forgot his name is big big clout whale
or something like that he put a million
dollars into his own coin
and he's he also has you know the
biggest kind of like nft collection out
there i think
well that guy bit he bought um he
wired me or i keep saying wired but he
sent me 10 grand in ethereum
so one guy is the guy who's providing
secondary market liquidity that's the
guy you worked with
then there's this guy who basically has
the whale coin it's a community token a
separate thing
uh he owns two million dollars worth of
nft art and he created a coin that
basically says hey i collect this art
if you own my coin you own a part of my
art collection and
um and so he's made he's made it big
he's made a bunch of money in crypto he
reinvested into nfts
now he's reinvested at least a million
bucks into big cloud as well
so there's a bunch of people who are
very very bullish on this thing you know
but um and and you know there's but i'll
also say like you know what are the
downsides right like
a if you go use the thing you'll notice
three things right away it requires a
password to join
that's already has blocked like 80 of
people now you could find it if you just
twitter bit clout if you google big
cloud password you'll find it easily but
today that's a that's a challenge it's
password protected because they're not
ready for scale
which is the second part you go use the
thing and it's so it's like under such
heavy load all the time that like
i click the follow button and the thing
[__] spins for 30 seconds it's like
super annoying that it's not a faster
app it's like the thing is always going
down because
they can't handle the scale right now um
jack are you are you gonna make more
income from nfts
in 2021 than you think you will from
your
real job or your normal business rather
probably and
three letters you didn't even know last
year yeah it's a different market man
different dynamics
very crazy would you say three years ago
where were you what where were you at
was it now march
i was just starting my agency so i was
shooting uh car commercials
on the uh like for uh you know just
running around the desert with a
handheld camera trying to
make a car commercial and
isn't it crazy how much things have
changed in such a short amount of time
the last couple months has been like
compressed uh a ton of um
just leaps and bounds of technology and
culture
and um last year obviously shifting to
doing work fully online i think was one
jump
and now like the normalization of crypto
is just feels like
another like rocket um and stuff like
you know what we're talking about here
is like it feels like that stuff is just
not just creeping into the mainstream
but it's just a burst pipe now right
like the
top shot thing just went absolutely
bananas then this big cloud thing is
going to pull on the same like
cultural levels that top shop did maybe
it's successful maybe it isn't but it's
like the cat's not going back in the bag
at this point
right so jack let me ask you because i
feel like
i feel a little torn right because i
come on the pod because
i come on the pod today and i say oh i
gotta talk about big clout why because a
i've been
using it a bunch for last couple days
one of the more interesting projects
i've ever seen
but b i'm like kind of embarrassed to
even talk about it because there's such
a good chance that this thing fails
that it's gonna look pretty stupid and
big cloud is even more
it's gonna look even more stupid when it
fails than like let's say like
i guess like what i'm getting at is
i think that it's you know it takes a
long time to build a reputation of being
smart and trustworthy and it's
easy to lose it in a day um you know i
think warren buffett said that once
and uh you know it takes it takes it a
decade or whatever to build a reputation
and a day to lose it
and so i kind of feel that way with
with bitcoin but cloud crypto in general
it's all such uncertain territory it's
uncharted waters uncertain territory
nobody really if anybody tells you they
know what's gonna happen they're
definitely not saying you know
tell me the truth uh people speculate
people have fun talking about it people
place their bets and then
the chips will fall where they may now
do you feel that way with nfts like do
you feel almost embarrassed
or slightly guilty you know selling a
file for 150 000 and you know let's say
next year the nft market comes down to
earth like i think right now top shot is
top shot's getting slaughtered um it's
going down like 30
month over month because all the whales
are like hey cool we've made millions of
dollars let's just do a coordinated
sell-off
and like you know like let's sell this
baby now let's take something off the
table
and so topshop's like cratering right
now and then as it starts to crater all
the people who thought it was going to
fail are like
see you know i told you so this was
silly to begin with
um as somebody who's selling digital art
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
does a part of you worry like what
happens a year from now when
you're the same nft you sold for 150 000
is worth a thousand dollars
and um what do you i guess how do you
think about that yeah i thought a lot
about it i think
um coming into it originally had zero
expectation of like the level
of investment that people would be
willing to
commit to something like this one thing
i will say is i've like
i have a relationship with every single
person who's bought one
so because the twitter layer on top
really the nft
layer you you often they have links to
twitter profiles obviously introduce
yourself everybody that
bids on the work and i think
that to me is you know if you have a
relationship with the person that
collects the art that's different than
throwing it into this anonymous market
and you know
profiting x off it i also think there's
an argument to be made for
like my background is commercial
advertising right so
i know you guys spoke to michael saylor
a couple weeks ago and i just have this
like
um i guess loop in my head or this thing
i'm thinking about around
what is a marketing expense relative to
a
like a uh a technology in general so if
you're
an ethereum like whale let's say let's
say you bought
x number of thousand ethereum at seven
cents or whatever it was back in the day
and you want to see the technology you
believe in the technology that made you
wealthy adopted by more people you want
to like
spread the gospel as it were feels to me
like there's a lot of people
participating in this market for that
reason so
the nft explained piece which was by far
the most
expensive um or the largest sale of the
last few
i've done i think they've got four
million impressions on twitter
so if you think about what it would cost
you to buy four million impressions on
twitter or if what it would cost you to
develop something that has
that level of resonance i think it's
easy to get distracted from that as
as like the three of us have
distribution but
that is a valuable thing right to own
something that has that level of
cultural
uh velocity to me is you know i don't
want to say it's
underpriced but i think it's like i
think it's
a uh it's a legitimate bet like if you
can see that this thing has
um this thing resonates with people and
that's the beauty of having
twitter so visualize value you can see
this image that you own
3 300 or 4 500 people clicked on and
said i like this thing
so there's also a mega advantage there
having that layer on top
where you can evaluate how like how much
this thing resonates before you sell
does that make sense
i yeah that does make sense and jack as
like
i i consider us close friends i wanted
to like buy
i wanted to i was willing to spend
around five thousand dollars to buy one
of your things
just because i like look up to you as
like a creator and i
actually think your arts badass and i
think you're gonna be like a far more
important person than you already are i
was willing
i so i get the sentiment now without
sounding like a douche
like i i have money right and i was real
only willing to spend five grand
the way the re the way that someone was
gonna spend 150 grand
that either they're like way richer than
i am
or they're just crazy that's
what i like i don't understand 150k but
like maybe some people don't understand
that i was willing to do 5k
so these are the people who bought
bought it very very well sure you could
like do your ethereum
wallet slew thing and figure out how
much people have but
well you said you know that right
like i don't have to i don't have to
know someone i'm like oh well the guy
drives a g wagon he's from dubai
some people don't have their real name
but it's like hey
um you know you develop a relationship
here here's how it works the guy who
bought the people
uh artwork for for whatever 69 million
or something like that
um i i i i'd be mixing it up but you
know meet covan
that's his has his handle uh well i just
read about him he he started a uh
i mean he's probably worth hundreds of
millions of dollars through bitcoin so
he's really invested
invested five thousand dollars into
bitcoin and is worth over a billion
dollars
based on when he invested it so he's
reinvesting
like i said you go to chuck e cheese
you're great at skee-ball you hit the 5
jackpot the tickets start spitting out
of this machine you don't think about it
like spending 150 000
you think about it like spending 70
ether and you have 70 000 ether or
whatever right so
he's spending a fraction of his like
giant stockpile of crypto bucks
and it feels different i'm shocked
there's that many people
that like jack butcher which who's like
a relatively
he's not people but he's like kind of a
big deal that there's that many people
that will just buy his thing for 100
grand i'm just shocked
that there's that many people who have
that i'm not on your own being shocked
right
and if jack if you do sell this thing
for 76 million dollars
i mean like obvious like
who cares about history and how neat
that is i mean that would like
that would be gener i mean that would
you the butcher family would be famous
for
five generations i mean that would be
the most absurd that'd be crazy
perhaps
it would be it would be just so wild and
so funny i
i hope it works i kind of actually in a
way maybe i actually hope it doesn't
work because you know what they say
about people who
you're not exactly this because you've
worked hard for it so it'd be like
selling a company for you
but you know what they say about people
who like win the lottery and how like a
huge some of them um a huge
number of them they end up becoming
mathematics and or they get
they're broken depressed yeah yeah like
they're already messed up
a little bit and now they're just even
more they're they're messed up times the
amount of money they earn
uh like i don't want that to happen no i
don't think it would happen to you
i would also be nervous like you know
the the fact that there's even an
outside chance of
it happening is this the most ludicrous
thing it's supposed to be like a piece
of art in itself right that nobody
interacts with
commentary on the space but the fact
that it exists on a platform where a
transaction could actually happen
isn't quite like just
unfathomable and that would like
definitely
warp your experience of the world and
i i can't even fathom what something
like that would be like but
um yeah yeah aliens will land before
that happens
that's crazy
okay we should wrap this i don't i i
don't know where we go from here but
jack thanks for coming on what a weird
yeah you know we texted you like 30
minutes ago or 40 minutes ago you hopped
on so i appreciate that it was fun
i hope somebody buys the thing i think
that would be [__] amazing
um i think it couldn't happen to a
better guy so
so i think i i think there is a um
i hope i get a text that's like holy
[__] and if i get a text today that says
holy [__] from anybody i know what has
gone down so
i hope it happens it's hard dude growing
up podcast is the hardest thing i've
ever done
it's easier to just sell a picture for
77 million dollars than it is to get
create a top 10 business podcast i
[__] you not it is actually easier to do
one than the other find out
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
my days off on the road let's travel
never looking back